hi I'm Philip my minh i'm an associate
professor of analytics and finance at
the university of bridgeport and the
chief analytics officer for vantage
sports and my talk is about sports and
esports analytics
the really nice thing about using
mathematic in a new field which is
something I hope you all do is no one
else does it I don't think there's any
other human being on earth who uses
Mathematica or Wolfram language for
sports or eSports and if you can find an
industry or a sub industry or niche like
that boy how great is that for you right
because all of these tools that look
like magic to everybody else are you
know easy for you to do so as I'm
walking through this whether you're
interested in sports or not you can try
to think how you can apply the same
sorts of things to any other industry
medicine health whatever so sports
analytics has changed in the past few
years and if you haven't kept up with it
what you may think is that it's still
sort of stuck in the Bill James era of
baseball and using regressions to try to
figure out on base percentage and things
like that that was a huge revolution
Moneyball which was not ten years ago
that was a huge revolution it changed
the world it changed the sport people
became more quantitative more analytical
but that is there's only so much you can
do with linear regression right I mean
who are we kidding the future is much
more data it's not just box scores but
like fine-grained data points like
LeBron James is standing at this point
at this time then one 125th of a second
later he's moved one quarter of an inch
or whatever I really find grain data for
which you need to be able to add to
manage large-scale data and do machine
learning and all other things and
visualizations and interactivity that
mathematic and Wolfram language are
fantastic at I'll give you some examples
of the stuff that I've built and you'll
see like in any other language it would
be virtually impossible so here's an
example so what is the optical tracking
data every NBA stadium has 29 stadiums
30 teams they have six cameras located
above the court that are tracking all
ten players at the same time using like
this Israeli missile tracking technology
using the center of mass so you know
where everybody is
right it's happening 25 teams for a
second so each game is about 40 mega
megabytes it's about 50 gigabytes of
data per season now between us that's
not big data right we're not talking
like Facebook terabytes exabyte pedlar
whatever it's it's 50 gigabytes but it
doesn't fit into itself
so everybody who's ever been hired in
sports analytics over the past 10 20
years they don't know what to do right
it doesn't fit and how can you visualize
it so here's an example let me actually
if I have it up I thought I did
let's see if this worked you can make
little video so you can interact with it
obviously right you can go this is one
play one basketball play here the five
players on offense the path they took
and you can go back and forward and see
where they were and what and where the
ball is bouncing and who is it passed to
at the bottom you can do certain things
which is the acceleration how much the
guy is moving per second acceleration
deceleration obviously you hover over a
person that says who you who it is who's
the other guy you can add the defensive
players and see how they move over time
you can add the referees and see where
they are they actually don't make the
referee data available anymore because
they don't want people tracking referees
are doing referee analytics but you can
switch to a different play you can see
what happened who did what who did what
over here ok great
fantastic another thing you can do so
any programming language can do a 3d
histogram fine that's no big deal but if
imagine either of those plots without
the basketball rim there right it's
nothing ready don't really understand
what it is the fact that you can
integrate a graphic that you can quickly
build yourself like here make a
rectangle make a cylinder make it
whatever suddenly add so much context so
the one on the left just to give that
explain what this is all locations of
all players for that particular season
on the halfcourt where were they and you
can see the coaches have gotten the memo
about analytics 1.0 you should take the
blonde three-pointers at the wings
that's the best place to sit and take
three-pointers no question anyone who
disagrees is the dinosaur like Phil
Jackson of the Knicks right so he thinks
he thinks threes are bad right oh but
they're great if you can get those open
shots those are great shots the rest of
the league basic and Phil Jackson - I'm
just kidding obviously is a huge
proponent of it - but what if you
districted to places where people
accelerate though they're all locations
on the right is where people are
accelerating at least half a G all of
those accelerations and decelerations
don't happen around the corner you don't
just sit not just fidget there right you
stand still for the three-pointer all of
your accelerations are decelerations are
in the paint are you setting a pick or
you're cutting
the basket so you can compare those two
of them together and that we quickly
give just a very quick rundown of a
bunch of other tools you can build and
think about how how much interactivity
and visualization adds you're trying to
communicate to general managers and
owners who historically don't really
understand analytics they don't trust
analytics they think it's trying to take
their jobs they think you're a nerd and
they're a jock or there's a huge clash
but if you can give them a tools that
they can extract the information that
they want so that they can keep asking
the questions and so you want to you
want to make the cycle of question
asking and answering really short right
now in most organizations occur in any
industry in any industry and your
industry in your business if you have a
question about your data usually takes
at least a day if not a week to get an
answer right let's look at all of our
bank branches and see which customers
have been with us the longest for each
particular branch okay so it's certain
SQL query but you have to find the guy
who knows it gets the data gets that's
cool I'll create done if you want to
visualize it that's another three weeks
now suppose you get an answer back now
you want to say oh you know I wanted to
change a little filter forget it you're
at some point you're not even gonna ask
the question anymore right it just takes
too long to get an answer but if you
have a tool like this this is a rebound
where the rebounds go you see the
rectangle this one's not interactive in
Fortune just a snapshot but if you in
the real world it is interactive so you
put that rectangle anywhere you want
here's another example and you can see
where the shots taken from that
rectangle where they end up where
they're rebounded right four missed
shots so if you're taking from the left
wing most of the shots you can see where
the rim is it tends to go to the other
side and this is a rule of thumb that
basketball people have known for you
know generations right if you're gonna
position for rebounds 60% of the time
it's gonna go on the opposite side but
now you have exactly right if you're
drawing up a play it's nice to know that
if I have a great three-point shooter on
the wing where should I locate my best
offensive rebounders well it should be
about six feet out from the rim whereas
if you're taking it here then it's more
spread out and you have the colors you
can hover over it and no telling you can
click in and it'll say this is the shot
that happened here's who was taken by
who's here's who was rebounded by and
now a coach that isn't reliant on you
there's no more friction between oh my
god this analytics guy is telling you
stuff I don't want to hear no now it's
all this this guy whoever he is he built
me a tool I have a tool great now I can
ask any question I want I can design
whatever I want whatever play I want
here's another example for shooting
obviously lots of different things you
can you could do with it but tons of
this is just a distance from the the
x-axis of the distance away from the
hoop that you are from the rim and what
is the average for all the people chosen
in that particular year of their field
goal percentage their effective field
goal percentage so three pointers count
one and a half times as much as regular
field goals so you can see the best
thing is to dunk it surprise surprise
right if you're right there and you put
it in good for you you have about a 70%
chance of getting it in because
obviously there's some defenders there
and everything then it drops off sharply
till about 10 feet then it's flat for
about 20 that's the mid-range game that
people tell you you shouldn't really
rely on right because that's about a 40%
field goal percentage not very good but
then you take a step back and suddenly
that big gap those are three-pointers
wife it's you're still shooting the same
percentage but you're getting 50% more
bonus or you put things visually like
this who can argue you can Phil Jackson
you can look at the one shot how it felt
how later led to another shot or look at
all of the makes the where they tended
to happen just a frequency thing this is
the most complicated thing I built it
for post ups it's way too complicated
but the basic idea is when you're doing
a post up how did you get the ball was
it passed in or did you dribble in and
back up when you shot was it a make like
a green or a Miss for the three red or a
pass out with the blue where were you on
the Left block write blog post points
per possessions these kinds of
interactive tools imagine building us
for your industry for your clients for
people that you work with right if they
can get their hands on it boy you're
you're doing a great job because then
you're not providing answers you're
providing tools and everyone loves a
tool provider here's another example so
this is a paper I wrote that provided
everything online for free it's it
automated general managers it makes
general managers dinosaurs a thing of
the past they should be replaced with
robots right because if we have machine
learning as better at humans in chess in
jeopardy in go right now the deep
learning with go week that's it go is
solved forget it helped but no figuring
out which athletes to put on the court
that's beyond the scope of any computer
program on earth right that's way too
complicated it's not it's very sit the
the interesting thing about mathematic
is the hardest parts that you would
think of Li you might think oh I have to
make
complicated machine learning mode that's
one line right let's just classified and
pick a couple parameters everything else
is just presenting the information
convincing people here's how much you
lost out because you didn't follow this
model you can you know if you draft the
oh okay machine learning here's a
problem with machine learning not a
problem with a problem a problem with
machine learning is it's a black box
right what's the biggest thing oh I
can't use your machine I don't know
what's going into it with the regression
it's beautiful I know exactly what what
each coefficient is how much it
contributes a black ball I don't know
what's going on you do know what's going
on here's one way you can tell people
what's going on you build a model and
then you show them the inputs these are
all the inputs right how old the guy is
how many games he's played and this is
from college bird what was his wingspan
what was his standing reach his max
vertical jumping position as they play
all that stuff fine and it tells you
this is for Kawhi Leonard who's he most
similar to back when he was drafted who
what is his projections great black box
not a black box because if you make each
one of these editable just a simple
drop-down menu right now you can
suddenly get anyone it's a tool and you
can see well what if I don't believe in
a particular number of him if I think
his defensive wind shears should have
been not 4.6 but 3.2 which is the third
quartile I'll click it I'll get a new
number boom now I get a sense now it's a
push back right now I have this in two
it's a real emotional connection to the
model it's no longer a black box it's my
black box and I can understand my black
box and fiddle with it does that make
sense I think building a tool like this
just a one-off Pricer going from your
inputs to your outputs where you can
adjust them with knobs or however you
want now people can believe it
right it doesn't feel like magic it just
feels like I don't understand everything
but for the particular guys if I have a
different belief I can I can see what it
looks like let me go to eSports now
because we go so another nice you could
build tools like trades right type in
people's names or whatever it's like a
little menu button you can evaluate
everything for you now let's do some
eSports who's here has heard of eSports
oh good for you
so eSports I hadn't heard of them a year
ago I mean you kind of hear it what is
that video games people playing Pac Man
or something right
no these sports are huge it's huge if
you've never heard of an overview kind
of third thing is just video games no
this is an industry that in a few years
or decades at some point it'll over
shadow all physical sports stadiums get
sold out where people come in pay a
ticket buy popcorn hotdogs beers and
watch the computer screen they watch
five people here five people there
typing and pounding away and you just
watch what happens most games are
interactive team games the typical cat
the biggest game the biggest game
involves League of Legends anyone here
play League of Legends yes what's your
rank nice
I'm a bronzy I'm still working my way up
Gold is very good bronze is where most
of the garbage players are like me so
you're you're a good player League of
Legends is a five-on-five game where
you're playing against three different
lanes I kind of like capture the flag
you have to get some objectives and so
on but and you can confirm this the
analytics for League of Legends are
ridiculous all you really know is how
many kills you got how many times you
died how many towers you got really
really small level stuff so one of the
things we've been doing advantage is
creating all sorts of new data and then
analyzing it so here's one nice way of
looking at things one important thing
when you're creating is team is your
team composition how do you work
together with your teammates this is an
example of we partner with a lot of the
professional teams for all of the
compositions we can figure out which
ones you're best at look how nice this
graph is and this is a lot a couple
lines of Mathematica code right so it's
a paired histogram and you put a little
things over here by the way if you've
never tried something like this the way
this works is on the right you have the
total number right so you have 17 tank
for the red team versus thirteen tank
that means it's a net four so you put
the four in the middle now you can
easily and visually scan down and see
who's winning what because sometimes a
paired histogram you can't really tell
immediately which ones bigger we've also
created a win probability model live in
game you tell you can tell how many
times you've died and they've died how
many turrets you took how many dragons
whatever and immediately tell you have a
probability of winning at 45% this is
really useful at the 20-minute mark
because that's the earliest you can
forfeit so if your probability of
winning is like 6% at that point you can
tell your teammates and they'll be a
cocky Feynman's play another game this
would be now much easier with version 11
you can make call-outs you can see your
how your win probability is going
changing over time right what was the
big jump down what was the big gap up
what happened the most the biggest
takeaway though if I could tell you is
what I end up doing with Mathematica a
lot for all sorts for finance for
analytics for everything is doing the
backend work the machine learning
whatever but then providing a website so
providing sometimes it's a cloud deploy
kind of thing where it's interactive
fine but sometimes it's just pre
computing a lot of different graphics
and packaging them so they look nice
together so here's one example this is a
game I played in July a Teemo if you
know you know teemo's cancer everyone
hates Teemo he you know he people like
killing Teemo and I give them that
opportunity by dying a lot in all of
this stuff this is an entire website
right it's just made for Mathematica
just runs on the backend spits out all
this stuff and it incorporates just a
template of a simple index dot HTML and
you know makes the little videos
whatever you want this is how the fog of
war has changed what you've seen what
they've seen again none of this is
available anywhere else but with
mathematic it's pretty easy to do so let
me give you another example so if you if
you're in a team fight this is not data
you can get from the core riot or League
of Legends or anything here so here I'm
a one guy against two guys you can click
through and it shows me all the times
I've died so let's look at one time
here's this is a 13 second video me
dying I'm a little guy Teemo right there
that's van to judge me that's me so I'm
just kind of walking the ring around
everything looks fine it's oh my god two
people maybe I'll make it out you think
I'll make it this time come on little
dude come on you can make you just get a
little more oh that's it
that's one tool what other examples
oh here's so some sometimes you can
build a tool that incorporates this is a
cloud deployed version let me show you
an example of this so you put in your
what's called a summoner name of your
in-game name with your name in the game
right you don't really have a real human
name the first thing it does is a forum
page so it spits out just the list of
your recent games okay so let's look at
my recent game I was again a Teemo
what this is doing now this is just a
series of hyperlinks in a foreign page
but each hyperlink links to another API
cloud deployed which itself goes out to
a bunch of different websites to get the
professional builds how it
professional have played Teemo and
compares it to how I actually played
Teemo here's what the professionals
would have purchased in terms of their
items and here's the garbage I bought
instead I'd see oh I got one one right
basically out of six right I'm terrible
I'm a really bad player I'll never be
gold I hope some day but another one
this one takes a little time but the
basic idea behind this one is you can
put in so you have different people
you're trying to make a team right
so suppose we were able to play together
they actually Wright wouldn't even let
us rank up together because we're he's
too good right you have to be within
like one tier I can't even play with him
maybe someday but if you're playing with
five people you put in their names here
together you'll see it'll automatically
go through all their history what are
your most favorite play champs and of
those all of those possible combinations
which ones give the highest win
probability so now you know what you
should play against the other team we've
built other tools based on drafting and
banning and all these other things where
again the the hard stuff the hard stuff
oh I'm not chief analytics officer I
have to go sit down and think about
models it's one line right it's
classifieds it's nothing
the the hardest part is making the
websites look prettier I put all the
icon here make a little bold you know
here's so here's an example of that
whole paper I put about automated
general manager everything is free
online now no GM has an excuse not to
not to have an excellent team let me the
last thing I want to show you is will do
something live let's do some live
eSports analytics so part of this I've
already done but then we'll try
something I've never done one quick
thing you know so sometimes you want to
do classify on every possibility right
what all the methods is the simplest way
to do that is you go to classify find
all the methods where they were they
were they ever they're here they are
selected it makes a little list right
same as that you paste it in you get the
first of each one and boom you have the
list that's the nicest way to do it
training and test data let's analyze the
classify for every possible method now
you may notice the drop minus two and
think what's going on for some reason
random force breaks in 11.1 it just
shuts down the whole kernel I don't know
what's going on it's a little too random
of forest
all right so in its modern Excel it's
almost done its own support vector
machine which is last one and we can see
how accurate and precise they are and
the confusion matrix plot so we're
looking for a diagonal of really deep
red and everything else kind of not so
much red let's see how it looks okay
orange is good too so 1500 versus 300
the the accuracy is 85% you can see it's
good across both the Markov didn't do as
well it's right more like 60% remember
so what are we trying to predict here I
should have mentioned this is all the
stats that we calculate for one
particular guy when he's playing a game
at the end of the game he has a certain
amount of kills certain amount of deaths
or amount of assists certain amount of
wards that he's placed a certain amount
of minions that he's killed a lot of
different statistics but he's just one
guy out of ten on the rift right so the
fields of justice where the game is
played one guy out of 10 is like looking
at one basketball players end of game
statistics and trying to predict whether
his team won the game right you can have
a great game you want you but you but
you lost right Michael Jordan was famous
for doing that then he started winning
so it's a bad example he's probably most
winning his player ever
so it's a it's amazing getting 50% is
trivial right a coin flip getting 60% is
not so great but you can get 80% now Wow
what happens this is something
interesting if you do it automatic if
you don't tell it what method to use if
you don't tell what method to use in
this case oh it changed it use nearest
neighbors but if you before it had
chosen logistic regression but I wanted
to have shown you is when you do it both
ways the just something to bear in mind
the automatically chosen method even if
it chooses the method that you chose can
give you a different result give you a
slightly different results so the one on
the right is if you chose logistic
regression one on the left it was
automatic with logistic regression it's
a little bit different just a little bit
different I don't know I think it's I
don't know I'll send them a ticket we'll
see what it is but it may just be while
it's doing automatic it's trying to
maybe there's a slightly different it's
trying to fit maybe throws away a few
data points to try to figure out which
would be the best one but it doesn't
really throw away because the totals
still the same so I'm not I don't really
know why it should be the same
ultimately right
this logistic regression um you know
where you're gonna go I mean there is
some randomness involved but if you redo
both of them you get the exact same
results so it's not that much randomness
all right great
any questions